irgendwas gut überhaupt willkommen bei
neuen video und zwar sind wir heute mal
wieder hier an diesem platz gelandet ich
brauche nämlich mein laptop ich habe
nämlich heute was ganz spezielles mit
euch vor und zwar werde ich mir gleich
ganz so lange wollte stellt keinen
freund
nein ich habe schon freunde kann halt
nur so rüber kommen als hätte ich keine
bei velbert mit uns nicht scheiße
alleine und zwar hab ich mir jeden
sonntag als fels video hot girls big
it's nice es oder so in der überschrift
standard habe ich mir ausgesucht das
gucke ich mir gleich an ich hoffe es ist
lustig und wir haben ein bisschen was
zum lachen ich habe mir natürlich ein
kleines extra hier an den start bonus
wir wollen es ja auch ein bisschen
interessant machen also leute bevor wir
anfangen mache ich mir erst mal zum team
und irgendwie schon ziemlich hobby
lothar das sollte reichen
jetzt habe ich hier auch das richtig gut
da ziehe ich mir erst mal allein durch
so wir haben hier jetzt zimt und hier
das video
ich tue das jetzt mein hund und ich
glaube doch dieses blatt für seine
tastatur berg ich denke ich mir warum
rennen
irgendein video über wasser
das habe ich jetzt gar nicht erwartet
das hat so heftig gebrannt was willst du
machen woche nochmal neuen löffel und
dann musste ich hier direkt das wusste
ich fucking video alltag
nein
kommt gar nicht wirklich
wirtschaftlichem und brennen person war
hier einfach weiter alles leute kann mir
mal einer sagen warum von diesem scheiß
hin
mein mund so krass brennt das doch
eigentlich voll süß oder so wie das hier
aussieht egal ein versuch noch ich lass
diesen scheiß zum jetzt in meinem mund
kommt
alba hatte dackeln
sie betreiben wir haben wir so einen
brauchen
nein gehört hinter hingegen gleich um
gewalt gleich zu sagen ja nah dran doch
gesagt der stadt vom schwein angeguckt
im hintergrund macht immer bis 5 nein
sie selbst ausdrucken
genau da für uns schlag wieder oben
drauf machen stellt das immer wieder
nein hier nicht hin man den kuchen mit
der nahrung angeboten
oder habe ich dennoch dieser mega druck
bringen
doch wollen wir so auf den wecker bei
auftreten
ich glaube das hat ganz gut funktioniert
mit diesem versuch nicht zu lachen
also an die leute die auch noch einmal
einen versuch wie sieht sie aus die
leute die bei einem versuch nichts zu
lachen immer weiter nicht lassen wollen
nehmt einfach zimt in eurer grund das
brennt so heftig nicht das brennt immer
noch meine augen tränen das brennt im
rund und an meinem kind ich weiß gar
nicht warum eigentlich ist ja an diesen
versuchen nicht zu lachen das witzigste
wenn jemand lacht aber irgendwie hat das
nicht so geklappt jetzt willst du machen
wenn es euch trotzdem gefallen hat
könnte geländer um nach oben da lassen
soll ich das noch mal machen vielleicht
dann mit einem kumpel und ohne zimt als
willi bock habt dass ich eine zweite
folge machte dann eine richtige folge
mit wem der alt neben mir sitzt und wir
versuchen halt nicht zu lachen weil dann
versucht man glaube ich wirklich also
dann lacht man halt eher als wenn man
sich zimt in den mund tut ins all of the
charges eingebildet da könnt ihr mir
gerne folgen wenn ich doch nicht tut und
links geht's weiter mit einem video da
ging es um meine freundin die 24 jahre
alt ist und ja wir sehen uns dann am
morgen schon wieder morgen am freitag
sehen wir uns wieder dort schon um 14 04
zu kommen morgen das neue video deswegen
haltet das schreibt euch das sind da die
ohren morgen 14 uhr im wird ganz witzig
und ja ansonsten schon da an ich komme
nicht dran